ladies and gentlemen comedian conserve
conservative columnist firestarter Mike
Bocchetti is here welcome Mike - will
diplomat you forgot about world diplomat
un member and representative absolutely
yes welcome you want to guess the right
people okay did he say anything okay cuz
I was I was wondering that was my
hearing or just uni decided to give up
on that sentence what are you gonna say
justice for all baby that's it that's
how you feel
yes it's so good to see you you know
what I'm gonna I go online all the time
you tell me I want to [ __ ] let some
idiots have it and read it on your
behalf I hate those scumbags don't worry
I mean they're all jumpy so you know but
somebody gave you some crap this morning
somebody gave you crap oh you mean Mike
everything's fine I think that's nice no
I know I know it is very very sweet but
everything is fine you don't need to do
that somebody should play my friend
wrong she knows it yeah they do good
thank you for doing that guy she the
[ __ ] Chokin his [ __ ] [ __ ] tonight
okay alright that wouldn't get the worst
idea in the world now I appreciate that
what did you think though I mean Don
Lemon goes on CNN last night and says
white people are our white men are more
dangerous than any other domestic
terrorist outfit you know I've stopped
pointing people out [ __ ] right well
everybody has everybody has you know Jim
[Laughter]
everybody has killer instinct in them
right if you G if you pursue a thing
that's four years you think people
should pursue it
no oh what is he saying now Mike is
saying that everybody has the instinct
in them to be a terrorist and kill
people yeah you were always saying that
it was racially based no no before he
was right yeah yeah do you have it you
said you you said to Jim's point that
certain ethnicities just have more of
that instinct no no no no no no I I like
everybody's chilling people know only
well only football in folks right right
now somebody punch into your house that
around is it a rock we're taking a feel
I had 81 no but somebody breaks into my
house right [ __ ] go off I be
grateful you did it with what whatever I
have necessary what do you got if you
have a firearm if I had when I bought it
you can come my house I'm gonna get it
there's no need for it no need to come
to your house if someone if they're
invited would you ask them politely to
leave if they broke in no you know if I
take it back to the rifle but [ __ ]
smash their skull our [ __ ] being that
first of all you do have a rifle rapist
broke into your house it was trying to
commit a rape while he was trying to
assault somebody in the house how would
you get him an allow a rapist to rape a
woman no me you'd allow rapists to rape
you saying what would you do he broke in
well I feel like in the hotplate
yeah no what would you do if I what
would you do if a rapist broke into the
house how would you get him out
what'd you do take away his head and
[ __ ] smashed up against the wall if
he's not a big guy if what he's a big
guy then step on his foot
gouge open the [ __ ] eyes again - what
I think rapists mainly wear steel-toed
boots to protect themselves just in case
is something like that anyhow the Oswald
model absolutely Lee Harvey Oswald
don't steal tip Lee Harvey Oswald models
did he wear steel - probably that's not
what he's known for
yeah I didn't realize it's not his claim
to fame - Doc Martens and producer Lee
Harvey Oswald the way Nike did it Jordan
maybe I don't know we got a look watch
the phone long we don't know about what
are you talking about Lee Harvey Oswald
and a steel-toed boot I'm sure why this
one I think he worked in a Book
Depository
let's I'm sure he'll kill look it's not
a serial killer just not one guy the
president to know why I don't actually
want one he shot no - officer Tippit uh
and he shot at someone else right he had
three like Connie in Full Metal Jacket
said he had an Italian sold where I
forgot three three shots off right like
Connie is four medals
rush to saw exactly right he's a lie
he's done he's not dead yeah I believe
he's passed he died absolutely
oh you like Vietnam no he died he died
during the Kleenex commercial is that
right you know that story that Lee Lee
Lee our lee Ermey you're talking about
he died doing yeah the next person did
not know that why did you say Lee Harvey
Oswald by the way did you mean Harley
are me no no all these different guys
gym thing is like do not know I did not
know okay
Ollie's all he was not a bully he's the
anti bullying he's a drill instructor
yeah I mean he yelled at a guy who was
overweight for eating jelly donut yeah
made him sit there eating while the rest
of and he called him numbnuts
no in fact body fat body way I mean hey
you got to get things done clean house
Mike if somebody called you fat body
what would you do I want to fight them
for sure sure they were spreading lies
like that yeah because they were a
bullet right Mike I have a it seems that
you in through a very stressful time oh
yeah here's why I thought Mike needed to
come in cuz the other day on Twitter so
you know Kathy Kelly Rachel up cut I am
yeah thankful right what can one time I
tried Windex well well not use Windex
Mike drank what he thought was Windex
but was actually blue Gatorade because
we knew he would say yes cuz we told him
if he drank the whole bottle he could go
on a date with Kathy Kelly not knowing
it was blue Gatorade he started drinking
the Windex 1989 I mean I thank God that
we put blue Gatorade in there cuz he
would have passed away drank the whole
bottle
the fans were pissed did you do like
they were because I kind of smarten up
the fans then we put silver so what did
you say what did you plan on saying like
let's go out now I drank a bottle of
Windex for you did you think that would
be well-received by a woman possibly you
know yeah but you know Kathy yeah so you
know she works over at WWE and she got
the they she's doing a show now that was
like a cooking interview show and they
do it on their YouTube channel but this
is the show she's wanted to do since
before she even got there so I I sent
out this tweet like this is amazing
congratulations like
you know great whatever baba bhot and
mike and this shocked me mike responded
to that tweet and said yeah great for
Kathy what about me
I keep getting [ __ ] over when do I get
my dream show I'm going Mike Lai's right
and so I wanted to know what what built
this week he's right what built this
frustration in you then you know a lot
of suits and ties with respects that's
the problem I don't think certain ties
would fight those faceless [ __ ] cows
and cubicles they're making decisions on
people yeah those [ __ ] you were they
doing here there's guys in cubicles that
are giving you a show
no it's you know what it's not just you
got it first of all you gotta create
your own thing
sure okay you got it you got to come up
with your own thing right the one right
the new world it's just been like that
for a while okay no but the bottom line
is okay I can understand if you know
somebody don't like you in this are you
mad WWE didn't give you a cooking show
and you wanted to do the cooking show as
well but mean what's his name Jeff
Stilson Jeff Stilson who's a comedian
won't create the Osbourne's very funny
guy
but I mean it's kind of an obscure
reference no no yeah you are a cue like
he's Gordon Ramsay
yeah I had no idea who that person was
no or where he connected to cooking or
WWE he was popped them look in the early
nineties she's a good writer good yeah
thank you any help create the Allah
Jesus you know women so you see you you
were you saw she got a show but you
immediately know like [ __ ] this where's
my show I use them very good like that
was stuff there's no reason to hold
anymore that's right you're right
because I thing is you're just gonna
watch him retail off an S cubed keep it
zipped to use put on Twitter yeah I
don't care I don't care you know what
because first of all I mean she got it
show why not you know but she's also
like 30 years old she's hot yeah why
they're giving our show it's not based
on merit no but she but she does the
good great what she does and what about
you is the question
you're great all you do - yeah but you
know you're also a little hottie
yourself I know I am thank you of course
no but you know what what is it what is
it that you're getting [ __ ] over with
by the cubicle someone I think you know
you come close to this and stuff things
don't happen things you come close to
tell me is show me a couple things I
think
unless Comic Standing for [ __ ]
forever I tell me why do you hate it
you let it out yeah okay this is just a
first time I get on there I didn't you
know whatever happens happens it was
nice I got some recognition right sure
of season four I was on some
well-deserved recognition you're right
he earned it they also give me a hard
time on seasons four who didn't when j1
that was on that the producers I don't
know exactly why they feel like the two
of you was just too much for the viewers
know they were like he's too much like
I'm like he's too much like him I'm
nothing like him you're not like him at
all no because that is based on the
[ __ ] stupidity of some douchebag at a
cubicle you don't do one later yeah no
we do oh no but that's my mister yeah
you're not uh James Jason in really
great shape
yeah looks like a cake Captain Caveman
you know what I mean you know there is
physically funny funny guy but his
comedy is very dark right and you like
Bed Bath and Beyond I work in the Beyond
Department exactly dirty and you are you
more of a dark comic or like no would
you consider yourself dark no because
I'm gonna went back to judge the mix you
a [ __ ] real [ __ ] why would they do a
real con tell me who were the judges
that's what Kathleen Madigan died from
cancer slum akak okay like ain't why I
got into the thing she [ __ ]
immediately tore into me for no [ __ ]
reason what'd you say she goes the
funniest thing I've seen is your pic
making fun of my picture right she was
shaming you you're an idiot and that's
for ants whatever the [ __ ] yeah ant the
comedian your pics name is I don't care
well I'm letting it out because he's got
it out what the [ __ ] negative the
roommate called a [ __ ] agent not
gonna be a [ __ ] infomercial exactly
so it's a right aunt what about he goes
we already had you in London
you know what I said I [ __ ] they I
cursed it that might even Canada tell me
what say we've already had you when they
go maybe you want [ __ ] paying
attention to me and what I was saying up
there you know what me at him he kept
walking my girl you know what [ __ ] this
whoa did they show that [ __ ] pity
angle so [ __ ] say but a bell up his
ass after that
executive producer Peter angles that's
right but see that we're now [ __ ]
working in a bowling alley in [ __ ]
Indiana now was it I don't know it's not
to dispatch people who work in bowling
alleys I mean that's a good job
sorry I just have do you think that's a
good job no you don't know and everybody
that works in a moment our garbage no no
no people have to work and make money
you know what I mean yeah but I mean
everybody do wouldn't do that though
it's a pension for money he's my little
buddy so what happened you told him to
go [ __ ] themselves I just got really the
other judge III Alonzo Bodden and [ __ ]
him to know here's a strike but he tried
to be passive-aggressive like this you
know what I mean what'd he do he's I
like you know you don't [ __ ] like we
shut the [ __ ] up go back to [ __ ]
summing up beefsteak Charlie's and
[ __ ] Cincinnati [ __ ] hack oh right
all right so he's selling out beefsteak
Charlie's in Cincinnati hack oh and
Kathleen Madigan is yeah you sure yes
I'm fine Madeline is a mother's [ __ ]
Madeleine - Madeleine whoo Madigan
[ __ ] give a [ __ ] because you know
what the management [ __ ] them - they're
[ __ ] nobodies in this who are they
[ __ ] knows that for let's go on the
street and see if anybody knows what
that [ __ ] [ __ ] is a lot of other
people matter the language I don't agree
probably some [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
right right now you look at Kathleen
Madigan as Nora see they're nobodies or
if it's something like William Morris
right you know what come and get me
[ __ ] you know where I am exactly
right so what year was my fault in this
business you know what you got you can't
back down
[ __ ] Mitch and who's got balls I do
that's right that's right afraid to tell
them to [ __ ] off I don't care all right
how many had that happen heart attack
two years ago you know what looking
[ __ ] blow me because right now the
[ __ ] about anybody in this make right
what year do what year was nice Comic
Standing I was a while ago how many
years ago is that 2006 you don't [ __ ]
play I honestly do that's about the way
to win time he's [ __ ] 12 years later
you let it out nother what brought you
to the point 12 years later she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] white so you think that
your career was part of it a lot of [ __ ]
that happens no just you know what what
did some things are out of all control
in this thing that's right yeah I can't
you gotta worry about would you buy some
things are in Arkham
only nice to you know she's an [ __ ]
she always been nice to me you like cafe
man very much yeah fake nice oh that's
why if you were if you were I was she's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] wreck I see and and aunt
was not nice to you he's a [ __ ]
scumbag
what's he up to these days I suck don't
make me say it I'll [ __ ] get in
trouble oh yes a are you gonna [ __ ]
give me a good one channel into the
Holland Tunnel someplace easy really
under the Holland Tunnel
so he's in trouble yes [ __ ] sucking
[ __ ] and rubble right under the Holland
Tunnel yeah that's in bedrock so Anton
bedrock sexual thing in French don't
[ __ ] hand jobs for [ __ ] 20 bucks
not even in water it's if it's under
bedrock in cement yes I mean so hang I
just had had it what [ __ ] but now on
to Boden you like them I'm not a fence
from him he's another guy everybody's
business like most famous words are I
loved them all him you know what shape
for some new [ __ ] so he was lying he
was lying he was he passive-aggressive
yeah they are yeah oh because the thing
is when industry people say I love him
the full of [ __ ] nonsense right so
what about the cubicles they're
anonymous people in there oh yeah dad
you know what you'll never find out who
pulled the trigger on you like turned
you down never did no boy you found out
who did it was is apparently on the
other end out you know you said a minute
ago peterandkevin bald-headed prick
[ __ ] Colonel Klink wannabe I see I
see now what have you what have you been
up to in the 12 years I've been doing
other things I'm so busy but I used to
write I really call it up something out
now called who's Mike Bocchetti and
Amazon Prime
right the documentary then I know I'm
serious Sam I got I believe you know
he's not even questioning I producer
something else called Bush Eddie's
basement and what happens in both
Shetty's basement is it a preparation of
how to prepare a body how to make a
sketch film an ultraviolet light I see I
have an executive producer I got
everything we said I didn't Peter angle
no I don't play with [ __ ] [ __ ]
guys he works in a bowling alley anyway
yeah you don't remember guys what you
didn't face probably [ __ ] head pin
Center over there now yeah Jim was right
there you don't play with guys what dick
I don't want to [ __ ] be on say buddy
bells 35 years ago you know I mean let's
pick the patient
Peter standing like that that was a big
hit but also guys why you why did you
make it sound Tori what sorry why you
make it sounds over there dude we're
trying to do the show well who is Mike
Bocchetti it's a film by Lee Schloss
yeah there's some cool people there are
some cool people no you can watch it for
free with prime if you have Prime at put
them doing sick sick series thing I got
an executive why did you make that noise
in the go-go next mute next Monday oh
cool those are campaigns never go wrong
right all right what who designed your
cover art Mike some [ __ ] [ __ ] I
said I guess it Amazon
let me see you're not happy with the
cover art yeah you know what it's the
best picture of you have seen you know
it does appear to mark over a face it I
don't know if it's a face or if it's one
of the things from Stonehenge just
plugged into Mike shoulders that is true
yes they bleeped it out as a big
question who is Mike Bocchetti to fill
my leash loss and it says Mike Bocchetti
is a and then of course comic genius
when we wrote that Dexter somebody sir
from what comics said that well they
always wanna madigan know know that we
quoted pottery they only talked coated
comic genius they didn't quote the part
that said Mike Bocchetti is a yes I love
Bob read he lost Marsh from you helped
me more than anybody in this nice people
look at this 5 out of 5 stars on all the
reviews strange and wonderful funny yeah
but the thing is most important thing is
tell me where's the [ __ ] money and
hand it over to me I don't care about
anything else anymore how much do you
want there's only eight reviews no but
accolades are good accurate a q8 yes
whatever you know what say for someone
who gives a [ __ ] so how much money have
you made off this documentary
eight dollars and forty three cents 843
that's not enough yeah
how much do you want to make off of it
enough money to [ __ ] go around and
tell people [ __ ] off pinhead I'm Mike
Bocchetti
how much money did would that take punch
money like more or less give me a number
in the high millions wait so have they
been throwing money at you they happen
no but it's all on sales but the thing
is and Amazon the difference is like
what Netflix
if you get paid a certain amount of
money whatever does but they own it
after that there's you want all that I
own this yeah but is this like a Monique
situation where you're not getting fair
treatment or pay for the work that
you're doing I don't know what the [ __ ]
I just want some cash do you think it's
racial no Amazon American is pro cash so
now 43 that you're bringing in but a lot
of the Kelly has a show you should I
mean come on she's a nice guy she's a
nice guy
God knows I've said that is there a way
to get that for almost it was just an
odd response because you spent time with
her and then to like you know for me I
guess you're kind of on the other end of
the defense on this but for me to get
the response from you yeah [ __ ] that
where's my dress horrible because you
know why you always been a good friend
to me you made me cry you own a fine
yeah let me look up to tweet see why
don't you ask me money make you cry he's
a good guy because you know why we're
talking about what's the pronouns no you
made me feel bad because I mean Sam
almost make you cry she's a good person
they're good friends and I feel like I
was knitting it but how did Sam almost
make you for me I don't even think I
responded to it no no but I just thought
about it because I'm thinking you know
but I just got along with him and I'm
like I'm an idiot now so a well had it
Sam I must make you cry that's the
question I think he sent me back a text
and said oh it so everybody I'm like you
know I was like oh but why would I say
to show me the text I want to see it
I'll give it an exact read we don't want
it we don't a guesstimate you can yeah
please actually you know what you can
show Jim I don't mind my text be okay
you can show you you should read Mike's
text as well okay I'm still looking for
the the tweet that I was I'm sure you
can
excited about posting and everything
because okay you know I thought it was
like good looking intently at that phone
why she tomorrow but never dad why did
you delete all the messages I delete
them a lot not all the specific ones
yeah well pretty much I can I can in a
minute you know Jim if you want it I can
show you my phone cause algal message oh
so much you make my babble yeah yeah if
you want okay
delete the tweets Mike yes I'm so sorry
that's what it is I looked at the
replies on this tweet and they're gone
yeah I was very ashamed myself like it
said where the [ __ ] is my dream show I
remember that quote he said where the
[ __ ] yeah that's great where the [ __ ] is
my dream shit's right where the [ __ ] is
yours so weird question I just didn't
correlate the two I didn't know where
where the two cannons they might have
had a choice between Kathy Kelly and
yields I mean you're obviously the the
competition for each other I mean it was
produced by WV you know she works for
them yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah see you
there for a couple years right you work
for them no so in a dream show do they
give it because you and her or you don't
work for them she does your mail she's
female just like she actually did cooks
yeah she cooks do you cook oh well you
know put you on the hot plate
what do you cook peanut butter and jelly
challenge is the best maybe you watch
the WWE not in a while but I can see you
don't cause of the every portion would
you don't watch telly W just went after
the wrong person because I was just
curious not you should went after her
that's the right thing whatever talk to
me yep okay
the text that I got again I didn't text
him he texted me so the text that I got
was and this would just all be the same
sentence so there's no punctuation sure
why would ya hi Sam so sorry about my
outburst on Twitter you have been a
great friend since day one just tired of
all the nonsense I get from the suits
and various idiots in the business 27
years of nonsense is starting to get to
me a little love you Sam Mike Bocchetti
that's good you tired of all the
[ __ ] and I responded
you're all good my friend love you buddy
and then he wrote thanks him for being
one of the real good guy
talks to and love you Sam Mike which I
appreciate it but the thing is I just
got to control my [ __ ] hostility I
got a lot of oh you it can't be I've
talked to you so many times in the last
12 years
and you've never been mad at Kathleen
Madigan once how come now all of a
sudden I can't tweet out about Kathy
Kelly without your Kathleen Madigan
anger named Kathleen the KA th column do
you think so
ka th yeah I'm looking for my Bocchetti
text as well okay please do oh oh I
called you panicking is there more to
this than just the last Comic Standing
incident no just you know what no there
isn't the last popular watch what sure
what else is there to have a [ __ ]
heart attack two years ago Yeah right
have you believe Cathy for the heart
attack no by the way Mike wrote can't
wait I said see it tonight she was doing
chip and you wrote can't wait
thanks Jim see you then Jim know you're
busy can i plug I'm going on chip today
online or wait until it's taped thanks
Mike and I didn't respond and he plug it
[Laughter]
you say no so no time no because she
should know I listen good when people
tell me yes or no sure but what if he
doesn't say anything then it's a yes yep
it could be it's not always right oh you
find that out the hard way Center so
your man at Cathy Kelly about what
happened to me I just went have to talk
it dad I just got to see how those cook
those [ __ ] [ __ ] in the cubicles they
are yeah what actors you did its movie
with Robert De Niro in between Oh watch
that was kind of a mind-fucking away -
why commenting I basalt I wasn't called
back for two different roles in that
film yeah
one was an FBI agent guarding him from
the Mafia in French Mike I don't want to
be insulting but in terms of just the
physical you don't strike me as a
stereotypical FBI agent yeah exactly I
got a callback somebody must have seen
from the right of me right but then I
had a role of a mafia guy coming after
him as well so I'm sure opposite ends so
but anyway what happened was they I
didn't get either one but
son the son the director right audition
for that film by the way did you get it
no I denied a terrible audition no I
auditioned for Luke was it the fault of
the constant cubicles Noah's not know my
lack of a gift so is your my lack of it
was the content the audition room me not
you right one of the worst I've had it
but the thing is so they didn't get
either one then Luke's
I said to me I'm gonna put you my film
somehow I'll write you into something to
put you in something so I want it being
casted as a city Jewish guy it was
awesome okay so that's a good thing yeah
it was great because we shot it on we
shot it around Halloween time in
Williamsburg okay let's hear what you
said about Cathy Kelly earlier cool but
I think Ali has a show you should I mean
come on you just said if someone says I
like him they're full of [ __ ]
and then you just wash she's a nice guy
after you bashed her that makes me feel
like you might be full of [ __ ] on I am
you are you are so my question is by the
way maybe she's a good guy maybe in the
intro sure um she's my question is if
but this is somebody let the horse
inside if somebody if something horrible
happens right like like Last Comic
Standing
but then something great happens like
you're in this de niro movie as a
Hasidic Jew wouldn't the movie cancel
out no and it did not long no why
because the Machine was being held at
him but the gunpoint at gunpoint
Marinero what's I mean some people don't
ever get to act with De Niro yeah it was
four hours of he's [ __ ] incredible
Sanyal he talked to me uh what happened
was I didn't say nothing in because I
never talked the celebs and I don't feel
courtesan like yeah no he right now I
talking us-led nobody he really is an
icon but the things I don't plotter
people like that yeah until you're
honest you know what I mean right so we
understand he starts laughing then he
talks to me he goes he should loot
better not let her she catches laughing
so we started talk and I had a mutual
friend why was he laughing about what I
don't have a good time we started to
loosen up a little bit you just laugh
cuz it's like
I'm in a good mood what a story so we're
talking a mutual friend emotion a Bronx
Tale with him and he was rich as pollen
Terry no no a lot of people say a Bronx
Tale but or it could be a Bronx Tale
bunch tale anyways if the guy who played
see no to God
big guy played Jojo - well he died okay
rest easy anyway so we're talking right
and just anything is he made me super
comfortable well he was a great guy to
work maybe it would have been more of a
bigger capacity well you're being
selfish yeah like how can you sit there
and be in a DeNiro movie and then turn
around and say I'm pissed off about that
now because my role you keep going back
and forth
one minute you're saying it was raised
if it would have been better if you
failed the audition process now Jim
didn't get the role either but callbacks
would write the bottom line is if I had
gotten that role I would have been one
more respected than I am now why is that
not your fault for not getting the wrong
it's not my fault nobody's fault you st.
DeNiro held you back never [ __ ] you up
didn't screw me up if she said he was
laughing at you and got leukemia I'm
sure if I woulda got that role I
would've been taken much more [ __ ]
sure Jim I'm sorry my [ __ ] [ __ ] hold
on hold on that role let's look up the
what's name of that movie was with
Michelle Pfeiffer was in it she played
his wife I believe and I think my buddy
dom Lombardo season
De Niro movie play I mean you can find
it right there it's at red poster yeah
oh these guys like I said I'm not
[ __ ] honest I was happy to meet you
so much guys dig it in this yeah but the
thing is Jeff how did you get [ __ ]
over if you've got a good much better
wall I would have been taking more
serious in this probably got a lot more
acting gigs than I did and that's it
Mike you got the opportunity to get a
better role and you didn't get it cuz
the audition didn't work out I know but
so he didn't get [ __ ] over you just
didn't succeed and now no well anything
I was in the character oh I know I've
got this role role and he did a better
job humble okay Mike if he did a better
job than you when I said he didn't get
[ __ ] over as a matter of fact the
whole experience was fortunate because
they worked you into the movie anyway
let me ask you a question what's the
bottom line I could have got more stuff
possibly but you didn't get you didn't
deserve the role
I know hold on you're saying I don't
know this room for our stuff to begin
with so if I don't get something good on
[ __ ] ball Jim could you make sense of
this for me I can make sense listen to
me right no I don't think that seriously
guys if I don't get something I'm not
gonna get another [ __ ] shot at yeah
here's the thing like but this one might
say he said that if he had gotten that
role it would have been better for his
career so you might have said but but it
would I'm Jim but but it would have been
people to give you more respect and my
boy Travis and Sam yeah have you heard
of Jimmy Palumbo myself I watched a lot
I mean I happen to watch a lot of movies
but I have no idea who Jimmy pull on
have you my name sounds familiar but I
would not be able to play so heavy is I
have not see so it wouldn't have made
you a household name no but he probably
better gigs me but my house sell act
maybe why should they have given you the
wrong just because I mean why don't like
okay I didn't I wasn't in the movie no
no but if they do be here or didn't
screw you over person you know put me
opposite DeNiro right if they just been
like let's do Sam Roberts and I would
have been able to be in movies but it
doesn't mean they dict me over I'm not
acting what did you and Bob talk about
he just talked about you know I let him
talk
yeah is that what got you like you had
this role as an FBI agent and then you
talked to dinner and he had you even
bumped down now I don't know whose
decision was but to think but the thing
is Sam why should they for this for the
sake of the movie why why would they
give the rose to somebody who's not as
good now you're right
well you know they do all the time oh
he's right you know I am an example
so your [ __ ] agent is better than the
end of the day it's who you're [ __ ]
agent is right let's give an example to
him so he knows because he's not an
actor yeah
no no Sam listen to me right listen how
many [ __ ] undeserved like like the
Oscars right come on tell them what the
Oscars right now right everybody
everybody in [ __ ] la know who's gonna
win before that thing has been [ __ ]
because up for not CIA knows who the
[ __ ] was gonna win but we know he's
gonna win because we know who the best
are no it's not the best it's man yes or
no [ __ ] no no I thought it's a value
system no values and there's no [ __ ]
values they don't [ __ ] who doesn't
deserve it cuz you're not you're saying
people don't deserve a key for example I
don't know when Scorsese won he didn't
deserve know I don't seem to have put
the thing it shreds him did he say
Scorsese did not get any Oscars know
there's a lot of lunch there's a lot of
[ __ ] behind the scenes yeah Sam but
so much the bottom line is it's all your
[ __ ] ages I don't I get that but
Jimmy Palumbo you said was better than
you would have done so why why wouldn't
the people making the movie put the best
person for the role his agent no I don't
know what it was but the thing is even
better I watched the movie right once
well I did watch her I want to see it
Jimmy did a great job he's [ __ ]
sanctionable he was but Jimmy was better
in that role than you would have been
and you got this but if I had gotten
something bad maybe yeah I'm better
you're right you should've got something
better way to look yeah but it isn't you
know why because Tom tell me if if I
don't audition a lot to begin with yeah
if I do you gotta get that's right he's
right if I don't get it I'm [ __ ] over
[ __ ] though yeah but they can't just
give movie roles out to people because
otherwise they're probably share much
commercial time you everything what kind
of commercials have you gonna have for
that he didn't get I haven't had a
commercial edition in a while
bit bit sorry I'm not grateful but the
narrow sounds very hungry right though
he's saying that you had a good time
with Bob on the set and they shave
something bigger but Bob [ __ ] you over
okay let me ask you though if a young
Jim Norton I know you I know a young
jump out
if he came to you say say ten years
after spider-man came out the tobey
maguire spider-man ten years later he
comes to you and he says [ __ ] the
business if they'd let me play
spider-man instead of being the guy that
says he stinks and I don't like him I
would have Tobey Maguire money well no
no not it not that but I know what
you're saying you're saying if you had
gotten and like Nick Nolte said AFF why
yes you had asked whereas holy [ __ ] it's
not even about the money
anything else is about being respected
g'morning right you would have got more
respect if you had Jimmy Palumbo's
career know his role maybe were help
that one role what year was this movie
2012 okay okay so that one was a little
more recent than last comic you're just
mad because you got a role you would
have been up there yeah but that role
but it was but the thing is that day
right yeah first of all he got on the
set I had a heart attack on though it's
an arrow it's [ __ ] he had a heart
attack no but Jim knows him from working
he when you work with him the great
thing about him is his energy [ __ ]
pulls you in like a vacuum I didn't find
that at all I'm sure we argued the whole
day no but it pulled me in the you're
talking mental is a negative experience
do you talk too much that he talked to
me anybody Mike you just said that you
yelled at Cathy Kelly forgetting her
dream job
I chose DeNiro [ __ ] to you out of better
be that you know what right am I wrong -
he was on the movie Bosch please don't
get me in trouble with him Cathy
Madigan's a [ __ ] nobody in this I
don't give a [ __ ] about huh or agent I
don't want any problems with him that's
the most important line
wait so you just don't want problems
with DeNiro because he's more famous
than Kathleen Merrigan yeah okay so
you're just holy [ __ ] - of course I am
what do you thinking you're done if he
was in that one of those Last Comic
Standing judges I don't know what he
would've thought but but but yep
the judges would I went on she's in
flourish I love Danny rime he's a nice
lady Joe yeah for the judges pronouns
are tough judges okay what happened
after 2012 that got you all fired out oh
yeah I might let it out I don't know
just you know insight into the biz
right chin most important thing is
around me I had a heart attack two years
ago right sure oh yeah engineer oh what
that I said you know what there were so
many people could help me to help me
after that right yeah every [ __ ] gave
a flying [ __ ] about when you had a
heart attack
nobody did no well what do you want
people to do at least you know plenty of
people know me call me up see how you
don't you know nobody did
oh you know watch them the thing is
Chinese people know me forever you know
what I can [ __ ] I would ask this guy
yeah I've had that person if they're on
[ __ ] fire now survivor speech no nose
right no no who didn't call you that you
want the people who you are somebody
else they like heart attack okay they
called Colin Kathleen managed and they
did narrow who called who didn't call
you can't say I don't care tell me name
one you got something on your mind say
it no it's a whole lot yeah it's okay
pudding call you
I don't football you guys reach out for
me and so do some other people okay we
do here we did I texted you didn't reach
out I'd like to know cuz it would lend
credibility to the story not [ __ ]
patient if they were on fire I did say
that yeah it's a harsh statement who
didn't reach out I survived just one no
no didn't I'm sorry you worked up now
I'll work it out
stroking here right now we don't stroke
let's take a relax take a breath okay I
got and then we'll say this one thing
right yep it looks great thank you very
much Jim we can't get him all worked up
again like what your car I [ __ ] have a
lotta yeah we want to come just calmly
who didn't reach out that cutter Jim you
know what they could [ __ ] dropped it
now who are you talking about no I don't
even care I don't know how much I'm some
bit I'm serious I don't want to [ __ ]
be worked up this right now just please
tell us if that's wrong I'm really
getting [ __ ] I'm starting to feel I
feel gay right
relax take it round wanna take a breath
don't touch all right
we love you you don't know what they can
flick an oil drum here's what I want you
to do my crescendo
don't get that time remember that time
you were in this room bunch of Asian
women sitting on your face my pals
sitting on your face cut cake show my
toes if you win hear me now right yeah
let's go back to pleasant yeah Asian
women sitting on your face that's right
remember they're feeding you cupcakes
remember that oh wish that cupcakes
let's [ __ ] snatch cupcakes
I know either way cakes I'm sorry
forgetting this work I don't like today
we didn't know what you ordered up just
relax you were just you were on a tear
you're bashing all these people so I
just was asking you a logical follow-up
question which was who didn't call it
because you mentioned it so you didn't
give an answer yeah but the thing in
common said when Colin had a heart
attack
I reached out from Jim I sent him an
email did he could reach out to you yes
she did yeah that's a good guy I said oh
you know her what happening I'm so sorry
well let's look at this video who's who
who was the who's the young man that had
a pile of Asian women sitting on him in
that clip well was that you we could get
to this still image that you just had up
Troy because that really does exemplify
well this was the Sam Roberts show yeah
this was back in the day this is one of
the last shows we wanted to go out on a
bang we wanted to throw a party for Mike
and they fed you cupcakes and sat on his
face no but Jim had a [ __ ] army to
carve a handsome strippers know their
performance her cigarettes see there
they are all did you hate them sitting
on you know occupation hotter likes it
okay I'm not a hundred percent sure on
the pronunciation but yeah totally
that's what I like Jim wanted curly oh
that's [ __ ] one looks like yeah what
black an Asian yeah Epstein looks like
Topanga from different world from a
different world
yeah we didn't like them cities on a
different world I loved it they were
[ __ ] smoking hot and this
nighttime it was I think I go back a
little for the cake yeah I'm just
looking about 10 tonight at least
roaster ok back a little bit there on
did you look at their high knees or did
you look away I liked it the pitch I'm
not a butt guy that much but it's cool I
see you are there you look good I mean
cake all over your face if we could
screen grab this and and tweet it out
just so people see Mike when he's happy
yeah hotdog muffins that was in Mike's
happy place you were happy then were you
happy yeah you see the industry hasn't
[ __ ] you over look at this opportunity
you had that is true cupcakes Asian
women on your face I'm the industry is
industry not there's a big difference
there's creative people like you guys
off there's talent and then is there
research to make decisions so let me ask
you this did the creative people when
you were at your weakest did the
creative people reach out to you yeah
who didn't I don't want to get started
yeah yes he's a great guy he texts me
and we argue ones that time I had a beef
with him at that time
so you who were your friends reach out
to you you know what I just write it
down
give it a rites just for I'm curious
myself yeah I don't know you know
watching my just so I could write this
list okay thanks one person Mike put
that ink to paper just one will put the
ink to paper one you know I feel like
we've done a lot for you know you have
okay I felt coming over here today yeah
I felt totally horrific and guilty you
feel terrific feel terrific
I feel like an arrow and analyze this
when he shoots the pillow
well after this maybe WWE will give you
the show that you deserve instead of
Kathy yeah maybe I'll fire her finally
yeah exactly and put Mike in them
you think the WWE social media viewers
would be happy that microphones Kathy I
think they don't understand he's an
actor he's a comedian thing is that
she's just hot she's right no I have my
key
she's a nice guy no she no she's already
not serious
greater what she does and she brings a
great job and she's a real person Mike I
should write that who write down who it
is I don't remember who she's like well
you're mad at them yeah you would just
want to thing you want to pull any
punches and always some Pulitzer punches
I thought I get wimpy now you guys would
you guys [ __ ] mellow me out we don't
want to know you
we just asked you don't say I just want
to talk about it it's like really will
you I mean you did bring it up yeah I
understood
yeah you brought it up and you were
coming on a tear yeah yeah but the thing
is go ahead and let us know male or
female let me say that could be
transgender okay Betty with the person
you're thinking of right now male or
female I don't know I'm not thinking
about anybody but me right now okay
think about a name that you would put on
that list who should have called you to
think about who should have reached out
uh let's say okay I don't know there's
so many idiots in this okay name one
just one just one
one it is one idiot I don't know of
course you do
why else would you have said that maybe
it's a bunch angled here we just do one
of the idiots uh alright name names no
I'll just go like this
Mike we're OK the Bob is head up and
down okay um I already lying everything
we did he called who else her Mike's
friends you might know I mean I know it
Pete Davidson
I don't talk to Pete that much to begin
oh I know when you were younger I guess
there was a good guy okay yeah I mean I
I guess I don't know who do you hang out
with negative reach down yeah I don't
know you know people could you know
Colin Quinn no I'm not I'm not
Colin's been very nice but yes I don't
know is that a nod or a shake in terms
of reaching out you know what nobody has
to do anything you said if I name names
you would not or Irish stuff to him when
he had a heart attack
client he got back to me I said him so I
know what happened to you what about
when you ask me like what I said to my
send them an email I heard what happened
to you you know what happened to me I
said you know what if I can help your
new way you need any advice I'm always
here for yes well Colin said that people
didn't reach out to him and you should
reach out to him again because he said
that enough people didn't reach out to
him cuz you know what they're [ __ ]
you give him another tax key no I would
yeah you show me Colin not people in
this business [ __ ] name what a Colin
say to you back here when you had a
heart attack what did Colin say to you
he's very he reached out to you
i I I taught a sentiment thing about
something he when he found out how does
that goes did he reach out to you Nick
DiPaolo God Nick was the one who reached
out to me tell Colin he got back to me
she did Colin reach out to you
no he didn't I see so when you reach
that to Colin then he was like are you
to Mike he didn't reach out to him no no
you should reach out to call him again
about that because enough people didn't
he said to me that enough people did not
reach out Mike no honestly it would
probably bother him about money but this
is right they put the bottom line about
this is if that happened to him and he's
been around a lot longer than his
bothers now like your name I don't want
I'm not sure we were talking to him the
other day down by where the fat black
pussycat oh yeah yeah and he had names
of people that he felt had not reached
out when he went through what he went
through so it might not be the worst
idea in the world for you to reach out
again and just say hey I was thinking if
you need anything cuz his is more recent
so he's still kind of grappling with
yeah another physical thought but how
bad were major very bad yeah bad enough
to die for eight minutes true but he
needs a shirt can we look it up no you
don't have to wait the computers already
off unfortunately but look he needs a
friend right now and he's what am i
[ __ ] puppy dog no are you not his
friend I don't like Colin Jim when was
the last time you texted him to support
him Colin yeah
pretty often yeah I actually I honestly
after the conversation I sent him a text
last night and I said hey bud you know I
know that I haven't known you as long as
Jim has but I want you to know I know
you're struggling right now if you need
anything please let me know and he said
a really nice texture
but you have more of a hippie type its
laid-back to me I don't know what you're
talking about right now yeah exactly
but you'll more chill like mellow let
him in Sammy we know but you just don't
text him Mike you should send Colin
Quinn attacks yeah he's gonna be really
insulted when he hears that laughs I
mean Jesus the [ __ ] tub leading the
shiny had a more pleasant day he's gonna
ask hey you talk to Mike about reaching
out and we're gonna have to tell him you
ain't just laughed in our faces
no I'd read no no that's for sure
sleeping now Oh probably he is uh now
some college he's up doing physical
therapy nothing no reach out to him you
want yeah it's we were just talking
literally he was telling us he has no
friends anymore all his friends
disappeared dickbag you're one of them
friend him I know said he was your
friend
yeah nobody's my friend McManus he
thought you were his friend
yeah you're a lone wolf yeah Oh do I get
a wolf howl did ya tonight you didn't do
that in the audition no I mean I were
you didn't text over to Carl no but I'm
gonna get back to the shirt addition
wise right okay it's not so many factors
going through with that day you could
have a great audition
oh man had Lenny a bad ones yeah I mean
I played the Romans actually yes I told
you he told me that's why he got their
own NAB it's all [ __ ] - you know
what maybe the people - could have been
people were better than him right now
but you know agent didn't have the right
agent to push the Mets right who's his
Asian I mean we I've never you know but
I'm saying there could have been people
to read first they were better than Paul
but not you know but it could have been
your argument about you know nobody's
right though yes you're right presented
any evidence no no listen omission this
is okay our people you know I love you
yeah buddy I'm I think they could have
been people who have well better than
both right but their agent they just
hadn't had the right people I mean there
could have been cows flying in the sky
but not impossible
well that's someone takes a plane ride
[ __ ]
it it's about talent it's about
abilities about how smart you watch how
you work right that's what I'm saying
but it's also who has who your agent is
but in a way your agent domains managers
managers aren't even as good as agents
so don't hate you pick you up based on
your merit no no we're just about $2
dollars right yeah you know you know
made you pick you up on how much money
you gonna make the medicines right if
it's about the agent what difference
does it make who they pick up just throw
anybody in there you still one time not
anymore now right a long time ago
the shipment I'm not following I know
anything go to gym like years ago like
say William Morris we're just moving
more years ago right right before their
endeavors a date would take talents and
develop them even if you were brand new
to this if they thought you were gonna
make the money to putting you develop
that's right but what if they don't
think you're gonna make him money no no
but right give anything all the time
because they took so many new people on
they were losing a [ __ ] Church they
were losing their shirts they had to do
something and it's that's why they keep
doing that they thought they were gonna
screw up if you didn't put the bottle
one into the house smart and not do that
any method for all those years it's been
nothing but [ __ ] mistake after
mistake it's a bad strategy
no but not well seriously okay what the
thing is no I'm very serious about this
right now yeah I mean with people like
that you got to be almost a million F
before they'll work with you yeah but
that's because they tried it the other
way and it didn't work I don't blame
them you know you got off so then how
can you be mad at me I'm just saying how
do you manage this system the system
changed but for the better now what well
yeah you know what but at the same time
like well me and Jim a new comics right
they should people development deals
like they were handing out chants not
complaining about this stuff no no I'm
Susan as an example like they get people
development deals like you know what
anywhere from fifty thousand who makes
five six hundred thousand if they see
somebody do five minutes years ago as a
comic right right Dave would think they
could develop a sitcom around bottom
line Sam yeah so many people had no
[ __ ] acting ability to it's right ten
to fifteen minutes Stan what do you
think enough a whole army of people need
help well nobody deserve it
you know what I'm gonna stop me about
Mary deserve it
who should negotiate in the gone no I'll
never say anybody shouldn't have gone
you just said a lot of didn't deserve
one who didn't deserve one I'm not
saying who I'm not a judge about that
whose dessert you're saying you said it
yeah I don't know I don't have one about
that because first of all comedy is a
very subjective thing I'm gonna tell you
something you're speaking out of both
sides of your mat today I know your
logic unfortunately I feel your emotion
you're upset about what's going on yeah
but none of your logic makes any sense
Nero screwed you over that sounds fine
dad I get ya dinero [ __ ] - you know
Kathleen Madigan a Content not De Niro
pammi so Mary Kathleen you know why
because she did not have to be a [ __ ]
obnoxious but but you know what I'll say
this at least Kathleen sent it to you
and she's not some coward - cubicle
right at least she's out the older what
she did not have to be a [ __ ]
obnoxious she just can't was she kidding
no she was and that was recent right
champ
it wasn't no what she can go [ __ ]
yourself now what her agent call me know
what I'll tell him well [ __ ] yourself
dick but I don't care who you want what
was the sign yeah yeah okay know what
[ __ ] I don't want to work the same
people she has every what if he's got
auditions lined up for you I don't give
a [ __ ] if I choose a lama to work with
who you want to work us give a name yeah
I got a bunch of people named wine booze
that day Becky number one Josh [ __ ]
okay I know my friends over three arts
Josh pause very good yeah all [ __ ]
guys this stuff well I think I'll have
me [ __ ] sitting around all day
machetes basement will help with this
yes yes what can I pull guess we have to
end the show yes he has to tinkle Mike
I'm sorry it'll be up on Monday an
indigo girl shut his basement I have a
producer for it actually
what do you know have money for well
what's the goal that you want yeah how
much 12 grand six episodes but at
Bonneville I wanted I'm raising the
money because I want to give the fans
good production value and come on grant
obviously you gonna flake for the top
the cream of the crop no no just rebuild
the studio $1,000